a tense exchange between two members of
congress
has gained the attention of millions of
americans in a speech on the house floor
yesterday representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez blasted a republican
congressman over what unfolded
during a confrontation on the capitol
steps ed o'keefe is on capitol hill with
more on this story ed what was the
reaction to her speech
well gail good morning house democrats
rallied around the new york
congresswoman as they called out what
they say is a broader
culture of sexism up here on capitol
hill where women make up just a quarter
of the house and senate representative
yoho put his finger in my face
he called me disgusting he called me
crazy he called me out of my mind
new york democrat alexandria
ocasio-cortez thursday rejected the
apology of florida republican ted yoho
for a confrontation in which a member of
the press overheard him using
a misogynistic slur in front of
reporters representative yoho called me
and i quote [ __ ]
ocasio-cortez says yoho made the remark
when he confronted her on the steps of
the u.s capitol monday
over her recent comments about poverty
being a root cause of crime
on wednesday he apologized for the
heated confrontation
but strongly denied using those words
towards his colleague
having been married for 45 years with
two daughters
i'm very cognizant of my language the
offensive name
calling words attributed to me by the
press were never spoken to my colleagues
and so what i believe
is that having a daughter does not
make a man decent having a wife
does not make a decent man
treating people with dignity and respect
makes a decent man on thursday
ocasio-cortez denounced what she calls a
pattern of dehumanizing behavior by men
this issue is not about one incident
it is cultural it is a culture of lack
of impunity
of accepting of violence and violent
language
against women an entire structure of
power
that supports that her emotional speech
triggered an outpouring of support
from other female democrats i was also
told in judiciary committee to learn how
to read
by another one of my members across the
aisle
these are the things that happen to us
all the time
i can tell you that firsthand they've
called me names for at least
at least 20 years of leadership 18 years
of leadership
top republican leaders say they believe
that yoho's apology was sufficient many
democrats feel otherwise
they don't even think he really
apologized at all and in a sign of how
extraordinary this moment was the
congressional tv network
c-span says that its clip of the
congresswoman speech
was the most retweeted clip ever with at
this point
more than 10 million views gail
wow oh that's impressive listen let me
tell you something yet i think women
democrats and republicans everywhere are
applauding uh
alexandria ocasio-cortez and several
good men are also giving her a round of
applause
have you ever seen anything like this
yeah yeah
i was thinking you're going to say that
have you ever seen anything like this in
congress no but we did ask the house
historians and they said yes in the past
there have been some examples of people
using four-letter words
uh just not in the tv age and so it
clearly was a standout moment just for
that reason if anything
yeah it's more than the four letter
words i think we could all take some of
her
decency class lessons very well done
thank you very much